o futebol futebol espera muito tempo
deste momento aqui e finalmente deu
certo deu certo cuidar que não tá em
casa tá em viagem pessoal e deixou o pc
desligado passagem que é que eu tive a
fazer música espaço todas ele agora não
tem acesso ao canal este vídeo aqui vai
ser para o canal dele mesmo o próximo
vídeo pessoal vai ser o como irritar um
jogador de lol 10 mas vai ser no meu
canal e vai ser a minha vingança para
isso acontecer só vocês têm deixarem
muito like neste vídeo antes dele ver
porque eu tenho quase certeza que vai
conseguir recuperar a conta ao falar com
o youtube por isso eu vou meter a meta
aqui de 150 mil likes mas tem que ser
mesmo muito rápido pessoal antes que o
modo que eu publiquei esse vídeo no
canal dele e o domingo que eu não gosto
dele eu estou na parte dele tem que eu
tenho essas aqui nesse momento todo
matar no meu canal na descrição por isso
inscrevam-se lá vai sair ao vídeo de
como irritar um jogador de lol bem essa
é a minha vingança eu tenho quase
certeza que ele vai conseguir recuperar
a conta só por isso não sei que é só 100
mil likes em 50.000 likes e eu não
estava ligado vai caramba só fazer isso
aqui tudo futebol não pode obrigado
vocês tem que dar não
e agora porque eu já não estou já não
estou pessoal sejam muito rápido sim
deixa muito like aí ó